the sony disney deal is something that
has been on everybody's mind since we
first heard of it spider-man is no
longer in the MCU as of right now Sony
released an official statement not too
long ago that said for the moment the
door is closed on the negotiations
however today we have learned some very
interesting news how's it going
everybody it's Warren and don't count
spider-man out of the MCU just yet in
fact venom may be coming as well it's
definitely been confusing over the past
couple of weeks wondering whether or not
spider-man is going to be staying with
Sony or if he's going to be shared with
Disney with Disney apparently wanting
more profit and ownership of spider-man
well today it has been reported that
Sony has actually offered Marvel and
Disney 30% of the revenue from
spider-man but not only did they offer
Marvel and Disney 30% they also stated
that they would like to see venom in the
MCU this is obviously major news so I'll
break it all down in this video but
first be sure to subscribe to my channel
for your chance to win an Xbox one or
ps4 I'm picking a winner at five hundred
thousand subscribers less than four
hundred to go so venom coming with
Spider Man back to the MCU now this is
something that everybody would
absolutely love however Disney has
expressed before that they don't want
venom in the MCU but perhaps if Marvel
and Disney were in control of venom then
they could put their own version of him
in the MCU now overall this is really
good news because it has been reported
that Disney originally went to Sony
asking for 25 percent of the profits
from spider-man and now it seems like
Sony is offering Disney 30% of
spider-man and venom to be in the MCU
now there are no reports on whether or
not Marvel and Disney have accepted or
declined this offer however it is pretty
much exactly what they wanted the only
question now is whether or not Disney
and Marvel are going to accept venom
being a part of the MCU it was already
rumoured that spider-man 3 could include
venom or Deadpool in it and if Marvel
and Disney accept this offer that means
that spider-man 3 could have been a
minute or it could have Deadpool in it
they could take it either way as long as
Spidey stays in the MCU and of course if
venom goes in
to the MCU we could get carnage in the
MCU as well which is something that fans
have been waiting a very long time for
so as of right now this is the offer
that is on the table according to the
recent reports what do you think about
this would you like to see spider-man
back in the MCU and him bring venom
along and do you think that this is a
good deal and do you think that Marvel
and Disney should accept let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and again don't forget to comment with
your favorite superhero or villain liked
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 don't
forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof